porsche says its new porsche mccann is a
sports car but our tester klaus needs
fitz thinks it's an suv at least
everyone can agree that it looks good
klaus is going to give the mccann a real
grilling as he takes it on the road near
leipzig
porsche has moved into the compact suv
market and it couldn't be doing better
in its first year production the mccann
sold out the suv which is based on the
audi q5 seems to be a banker for
proportion
klaus says when it gets going you feel
good in the driver's seat
it's sporty but very stable you need
that too this car holds the road well
that's thanks to porsche's torque
vectoring plus system it gives the outer
rear wheels more power and allows
drivers to accelerate faster out of
curves
klaus says the dual clutch transmission
makes the driver's life easier the
steering wheel has paddles to let you go
up or down a gear just as in a sports
car
the 3-liter engine puts out a powerful
250 kilowatts mccann means tiger in
indonesian and this tiger can really
roar
the car can go from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in just 5.2 seconds
is perfect again it's like a sports car
it's firm and direct and it helps to
make the steering very precise through
the curves
at the apex you can give it some gas and
go into oversteer very easily the whole
thing is very simple and easy to control
to
control
all this means that despite their shared
origins the mccann is a totally
different beast to the audi q5
so now klaus wants to know if it copes
with rougher terrain just as well
to see if it can really be called an suv
the series standard off-road setting
gives the car an extra 40 millimeters
ground clearance
all the relevance available
a 100 percent grade is no problem for
the mccann
the hill start assistant helps keep the
speed constant that also helps on steep
down hills
it easily copes with a 45 degree sight
incline too
the variable torque distribution makes
it grab the road surface
says the ability to distribute power
totally variably according to the
driving situation sets their system
apart
torque distribution from the front to
the rear axle is completely variable
our sports cars are rear wheel driven
which is classic for a sports car all of
porsche's suvs are all-wheel drive
the mccann feels almost like a 911 but
not quite because with a weight of 1.9
tons you never completely forget you're
in an suv
he often
on normal roads klaus thinks the mccann
drives like any other suv it's very firm
and very comfortable so it's got
everything you could want from a sports
vehicle
the mccann has many sports car features
the dynamic corner light covers the bulb
depending on the speed the car is
traveling
at the back the car has two double
exhaust pipes
the trunk space starts at 500 liters but
that can be increased to 1500 liters
the design is similar to the panamera
and the 911 a range of three engines are
offered we tested the mccann s which
starts at 58 000 euros
if you want your tiger turbocharged
you'll have to shell out almost eighty
thousand
five says even though the mechanic isn't
a sports car it's the sportiest suv he
knows and it has everything you need
with comfort luxury and enough space for
the whole family